[Music]
it's Michelle from love muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD skin can earn and
threatenin fan today I'm going to be
talking about how to start on threatenin
adapt alene and other powerful retinoids
treasure Nolan is one of the most
science-based skin care ingredients but
it's notoriously hard to start on
there's lots of peeling and irritation
involved and I might have gotten broken
capillaries from the first time I tried
retinol there's even a technical name
for this break-in period retinas ation
so to help you start on it and to avoid
all the mistakes I made here are some
tips on how to add it to your routine
with minimal side effects so you can get
the benefits without freaking out your
skin
if you like this sort of video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to my channel and
make sure you click the notification
bell so that you don't miss any videos
[Music]
retinoids are vitamin a derivative for
example tretinoin
retinol different which is a dappling
and teaser routine they're really
popular ingredients in skincare and it's
also in accutane which is isotretinoin
and ro medication they have very
powerful anti-aging anti acne and anti
pigment effects and there are lots of
scientific studies to back them up the
main drawback to these Holy Grail
skincare ingredients is irritation this
means dry flaking peeling skin stinging
and redness this usually happens in the
first few weeks until your skin
eventually gets used to it some people
don't get this irritation at all and for
some people it takes up to six weeks
to stop out of the retinoids threatenin
is one of the most irritating but the
benefits are also best supported by the
evidence to zero teen is more irritating
but adapt lean retinol and retinol
dehyde are less irritating I was
particularly scared to start at retinol
because back when I tried 1% rationale I
went a bit true hard I have pretty
resilient skin and nothing really hurts
it and it recovers really quickly not so
much with retinol I used too much too
quickly my skin is actually quite
sensitive to it and this irritation has
a bit of a delay it doesn't happen the
next day it happens the day after so
it's a bit harder to adjust how much I
use base on my skin's feedback and you
need to have some self-control which I
don't really have I also had a cold at
the time and so I blew my nose a lot and
I think the combined irritation gave me
broken capillaries since retinoids
increased skin irritation they can also
cause purging which is when a product
makes your skin worse before it gets
better
because basically it makes your skin
expel all the baby pimples that were
there much faster I have a video on how
to tell if your skin is purging or
breaking out and whether to stop your
product or to wait until it blows over
purging is worse when your skin's
irritated so it's best to add the
treasure known in slowly so that your
skin can adjust the two main ways to
limit how purger your skin gets is to
introduce the product slowly and to look
after
your skin and so that's the aim of my
tips here retinol eye products tend to
come in lots of different percentages
and it's recommended that you start with
a formula that's this gentle as possible
so for example you can look for lower
concentrations and time-release cream
formulas are also more gentle than gels
and they also tend to be more effective
at delivering the medication to your
skin as well there are a few different
strategies for adding retinoids and
slowly basically you want to put it in
as low as possible without losing
patience some strategies are using a
lower concentration of building it up so
you can use the lower concentration in
the formula or you can try to dilute it
with oil or cream you can also try alter
in a day application which is pretty
self-explanatory just use it every
second day or third day at first there's
also short contact therapy which is
where you apply the product like a mask
and rinse it off there's a few studies
where short contact gave good results in
one study on acne a daily nor point
naught 5 percent tretinoin cream applied
for half an hour gave comparable results
to leaving it on and a lot less people
about 20% had irritation even without a
moisturizer other considerations include
using mild skincare so using gentle
cleansers and moisturizers and avoiding
things like acid exfoliants while your
skin is getting used to the retinoid you
should also try not to apply the
retinoid while your skin's wet because
it's easier for ingredients to penetrate
wet skin so after you cleanse wait about
half an hour before you apply it it also
helps if you apply the product evenly
you tend not to apply very much and so
you want to spread it out over your skin
so you don't end up with hot spots one
technique is to jot it around your face
and rub it in you can also dilute it
with a cream or moisturizer and then put
it on as well I'm using my routine as an
example that you can follow or you can
adapt at your own needs the product I
started with was no point not 5% treta
Nolan or retinoid acid the brand name is
retin-a but I used a generic version
which in Australia is $30 for 25 mils
which is much cheaper than most non
prescription retinoids and it's a lot
better regulated so it has a much better
chance of working
the way it's intended for the first week
I did short contact therapy with half an
hour in the evening three days apart I
used two half pea-sized amount each time
and washed it off with a gentle cleanser
I used really gentle skin care like a
humectant toner moisturizer
I tried strategy a liquid gold and dr.
jutsu compared cream and I found that
seeker pear was more effective for my
first week I had zero irritation or
peeling and only a little bit of dryness
but I also didn't really have any
results although I didn't get any new
pimples so the next week I stepped it up
so the second week I left it on my skin
but I applied an oil underneath I put a
really thick layer of oil so something
like strategy or fortify or huxley
secret of Sahara oil light and all and
then I applied about a quarter p amount
on my face though all helped the cream
spread around really evenly and I used
to moisturizer afterwards so the same
ones from the first week on the days I
wasn't using triton on I used a
humectant toner or a really weak aah a
product this is when the peeling really
started there was a lag time of about a
day and a half and so i would start
peeling in the middle of the day and it
would clear up after about a day there
was also a bit of dryness and some mild
stinging one tip for makeup if your
skin's peeling is to just use concealer
rather than foundation because it makes
the flakes look a bit less obvious by
this time I was meant to get a few big
pimples around this time of the month
but I didn't get any which was nice but
it could have also been a fluke I also
noticed that some post inflammatory
hyperpigmentation was fading a bit
faster than usually would because that
meant quite well for the next two weeks
I applied the threatenin to bare skin
every third day I used to quarter
pea-sized amount and I put it on dry
skin and I tried to keep it away from
areas that get really irritated and
flaking so around my nose and around my
chin I put moisturizer on afterwards and
I used a weak alpha hydroxy acid product
the night before for these two weeks I
started with some irritation but by the
end I pretty much had no irritation or
peeling by the end of week four I could
use the tretinoin every second day I've
talked about my final routine in detail
on my blog which I've also linked in the
description but here's the gist of it I
have a three day schedule which rotates
on the first night I use a quarter to
half pea-sized amount of threatenin on
the other days I alternate between alpha
hydroxy acid and vitamin C and I use
niacinamide on all the nights I found
that this was the best combination for
me in terms of results I found that true
anam really helps with the texture of my
skin so how smooth it is how big my
pores are it also helps with how my skin
looks so it's a lot clearer and a la
Chloe uh and this is probably down to
the fact that threatenin makes your
stratum corneum more compact this is the
layer of dead skin cells on top of your
skin I have found though that I still
need alpha hydroxy acid to keep the
called pores in check and I still need
vitamin C to fade the hyperpigmentation
much faster I found that with this
routine I don't get much irritation or
flaking while I still get all the
benefits of the ingredients I made a lot
of mistakes when I first started so I'm
listing them here so you don't make them
too my first mistake was using way too
much way too often this is a really easy
mistake to make especially if your skin
is generally quite resilient treat it
like it's kryptonite mistake number two
is using the retro noise and then using
other irritating things like alpha
hydroxy acids next I accidentally used
10% alpha-hydroxy acid during week two
and the next day I had the tightest and
most stinging face when I was applying
basic things like sunscreen and
foundation five percent was okay for me
at the beginning 10 percent became okay
for me later on but at the start just
don't do it I also made the mistake of
using a humectant toner before applying
the rationale at the beginning and later
on every less this made my skin more
permeable and more prone to stinging so
I hope you found this video useful if
you did give it a thumbs up and you can
subscribe to my channel for more videos
like this you can also follow me on
instagram at lab muffin PG science and
check out my blog for more nerdery see
you next time